they got loud music playing and he's
normally it was the rock music like
heavy metal
music on for like 24 hours 48 hours and
they make it really cold so they put the
aircon really cold are you there are in
that position another your leg starts
cramping your calves cramp
hamstrings and camping your bum's
cramping comes in your belly Comes Here
Comes you can't you can't get out
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from lad
Bible I'm Ben Paul Jones and we're
joined in the studio today by ruhal
Ahmed uh great to have you with her
thank you thanks for having me for
anyone listening who's not aware of who
you are would you mind giving a brief
introduction my name is rohal Ahmed I
live in Sandwell in the UK and there was
a Texas
for two and a half years
okay so obviously Guantanamo Bay is an
uh something that a lot of people are
interested in as a piece of kind of
modern culture and it's something we
don't often get to talk about especially
not with detainees so I guess
let's
jump straight into it because where I'd
love to spend the majority of this
conversation is is on what happened to
you and what you you've become well
known for you know what are the events
that led up to you being detained in
Guantanamo Bay starting from your time
in the UK
yeah um during the time I left the UK I
think it was
2001.
if I can remember it's been it's been a
it's been a few years
um my friend was getting married one of
the guys who was in prison with me um as
if
he was getting married in Pakistan so we
actually traveled to Pakistan to for his
wedding and how old are you here uh we
were 17 17 and when you say we there was
a there was a group of us there's four
of us who left the UK for his wedding so
it was all it was all childhood friends
we went to uh primary to college to to
high school
um so we hung around together as also we
went to all the youth clubs so we was
very very close as friends so it was
friends in school and out of school so
when he turned 18 I was 17 at the time
but he turned 18
um
being in from an Asian background is
quite normal for our parents to arrange
our marriage or his his father had
arranged his marriage in Pakistan with
with his wife
um to be wife so obviously we went to
Pakistan for that for that reason
initially and obviously 911 has happened
we didn't really have much idea what was
going on being 17 years old you don't
really pay attention to the news
especially with
things that happen in America
um 9 11 to that extent so anyway we went
off to Pakistan
um we had a few weeks to chill we did
what we want to do we traveled
throughout through throughout Pakistan
it wasn't your first time traveling
there it was my first time traveling to
Pakistan but not out of the country so
I've traveled to my to my home country
which is Bangladesh three times prior to
that and I went on my own the last time
I went when I was 16 I traveled on my
own
so going to Pakistan was like going to
Pakistan it's the same kind of country
it's only like two doors away we have
very similar cultures uh so there wasn't
anything particularly huge or intense
for you it was another trip you're
excited yeah I mean like a lot a lot of
people ask me this question but why
don't you wasn't too scared to go to a
country like Pakistan
if I was what my name was John Smith
tell me I would okay but um my name is
and I'm a Muslim we've been traveling
around two different cities
um and eventually
we we stayed in mosques because in them
kind of countries if you can stay in
mosque for free that allows you to allow
you to go and stay if you ask the
principals or you go to the office and
say look Travelers can we sleep and they
allow you to sleep in the in the courts
so we stayed in mosque because it was
cheap we didn't have much money and
being 17.
um and eventually like there was a lot
of there was a lot of rallies going on
in Pakistan about 9 11 about helping the
the um devgani people because the wars
was kicked off we wasn't really aware
what's going on or we knew we was kind
of
I wouldn't say groomed but
pressured in a way
to to go to a to go to Afghanistan help
with Aid and we thought you know we've
got a time we don't mind so we jumped on
the bandwagon and and we end up in
Afghanistan and how long after 9 11 was
this
so 911 happened in September we went to
Afghanistan in I think October okay so
very very close okay sure October
November yeah
so you see so talk us through it so you
um you were all four did you say four of
you wasn't it there was a photo there
was four levels in total who who
eventually went obviously with the with
the amount of people that were those
hundreds right when he was on the buses
there was all the buses and stuff
so as soon as we get to Afghanistan
um we're going to the Border we got to I
think it was Kandahar and he got it was
I would say it was about
Nightfall so it's quite late and all of
a sudden over here is Boom
for a second I thought San Luis
and obviously we've looked at the window
and I'll always all we see is just
flashes and bomb dropping and now I'm
like panicking thinking well what's
going on here and they're like well
there's this war so in my mind I'm
thinking yeah not this war but why is it
happening here why is it happening as
we're driving you know we can feel the
vehicle shake what what happened next so
from what happened was I think we was in
Canada if I remember correctly from
Kandahar we was there for a week
we're gonna get you back to Pakistan to
the Border
um so they eventually arranged a car we
got in the car we paid for the what they
said to us we've got to pay for a number
of people to go with us instead of
sending us back to
extend to the Border they sent us
further up north into Afghanistan they'd
send us to to Kabul
and they did that on purpose obviously
now realizing at the time I never knew
what was going on but now obviously
realizing they they sent us to cable on
purpose because we had to pay for the
fuel for the taxi for the guys the guys
that they they who travel with us
I think there was about nine of them in
total we paid for their travel there was
all actually the part of the foreign
Fighters
so we got the cable and I think okay
they said they say Pakistan because with
now we've been in a military compound
they they asked the guys who who we were
with and said oh what's happened and
they obviously told them what the score
is they didn't tell us so now they're
saying okay we're gonna put you in a
house you stay there
for a few days and we're going to try to
arrange a transport for you to go back
right so I'll be there for I think
another week
and again they arrange another car
instead of going
to back to Kandahar
they take us further up north
so now now I'm in like the front line
where the war's actually taking place
was it the same deal they used you to
pay for yeah basically yeah
so we get the same problem
communication is a massive issue the
guys we traveled with they've they've
gone to wherever they need to go so now
we're left in the middle of nowhere
with nobody
and where are you is it like a city or
is it room is it city is it town it's a
town in the middle of the middle of the
city but they had like their their
training camps so obviously that's where
the car stopped so obviously we found we
asked around who's who's in charge we
asked around that guy came he didn't
speak very good Urdu at all my order's
not great because
communicated they said you know we're
going to give you a play to stay stay
there we'll arrange something so we
stayed there for two weeks it's getting
quite repetitive yeah so obviously being
17 and like being in a country where you
have no power yeah you've got no
one to go to no place there's no one to
complain to You're Gonna you kind of got
gonna go along with what they say
because you've got another option but
you're still at this point because like
if that has been me I would have been
regardless of which country it was I
would have been panicking yeah panicking
we were panicking but there's
in that situation what do you do you can
panic in a room but what do you do like
you you kind of in a in a massive cage a
cage where the you know you're allowed
to freely go whenever you want
but at the same time you can't um
so we wasn't restricted in terms of like
we couldn't go to the we could go to the
shop go to the bazaar we could go and
buy food go to a restaurant we do all
that
so we wasn't restricted they didn't even
ask or come and check on us at night if
you're still there they don't care but
they would come every day with food and
say no we're laying out tomorrow
okay so that was a you know it it was it
was quite
peace you know peace of mind to know
that we could do what we wanted in that
terms of going out and coming back
freely no one following was
um but obviously we couldn't leave in a
taxi and go
and would you weren't worried about them
thinking that you were British or like
they knew he was British because
obviously spokenish but they weren't you
weren't worried about like passports
being taken you know they just it just
felt like they weren't they asked us
obviously no have you got your password
you got your documentation with you have
you got have you got money with you you
said yeah we've got everything with us
and and not not at one point asked can
we see your documentation can we see
your passport can we see the amount of
money you've got and when you look back
now why do you think they weren't
sending you back I think what it was the
the initial group that used was to go to
Kabul and then send us to Afghanistan
and two Condors they just use those as a
means of
Finance yeah really to go to get their
people over to places and the people
just the their ticket really right
obviously when we've got there the guys
in charge there they thought well we
don't know nothing about this so
obviously I think they're all doing
their best to send us back but I think
we didn't know what was going on behind
the scenes between the Taliban and and
and the US what was going on because
obviously they lost power and they was
retreating so they never come and told
us this kind of stuff that we're gonna
you know when we negotiate of
surrendering we never knew we just they
just told us every day we don't know
ourselves what's going on we will let
you know if you can go back okay and
then and then what's the next chapter in
this story then so basically what
happens is
um after I think about being there for
two weeks they come and say we're gonna
leave today we're obviously excited and
happy so we go to town we we pack our
bags it's just rucksacks and wherever
uh we get some snacks and stuff for the
journey water
um some food and stuff and then they
they said wait just wait here our cars
will come and just jump in into the cars
and all these cars and lorries and buses
they're all going to go towards towards
Pakistan we're gonna go to Kabul then
Kandahar hey eventually we're going to
go
but at no point no one said that they're
surrendering
so obviously we're standing in the city
in in the town
already left there Carl come you've
jumped in waiting I also suddenly just
see trucks and trucks military trucks a
convoy of cars and lorries and all the
fighters are on there
with with them all all geared up you
know with arms and stuff
and obviously now we see all different
types of nationality there there's
white guys there there's black people
there tajikis uzbekis they all look
different so you obviously know them now
from this country you know pakistanis
obviously now we can speak so okay
what's happening
um the Taliban have made a deal with
General Dustin
um that they're gonna we're gonna
surrender we're gonna we're gonna give
up this city and he will give us a site
we're gonna give up our arms and our
vehicles and they will escort us back to
Canada because at that time they lost
Kabul Taliban lost Kabul but they're
still they had they had the hole in
Canada
so that was a deal
so obviously we're thinking okay why are
we gonna send why do we have to go with
you they said well there's no other way
out really you've got to come with us
and they'll escort us together
to me okay it's fine we'll we'll do that
we do we do what we do
So eventually we got two
out of the city and it's all it's all
better desert now it's all like desert
mountains to go to the next city
and it's it's about
8 P.M gets dark all of a sudden we can
just hear helicopters Apache can't see
them also organ sees flashes on the sky
and obviously all the fight I think
there was about 35 000 people at that
time surrendering
and every sauce running can you have the
cars and the the bomb like the vehicles
where there was ammunition so the
ammunition was exploding going
everywhere so we was running like
chickens headless chickens in the
mountain in a cave trying to hide in the
bushes so all night we basically ran
around
shelter in the morning
all we see just people dead
loads of people dead
someone's got the arm missing someone's
got a legacy and someone's been shot
bully holes heads over here bodies over
there people are crying
to help them
it's obviously we in the in that morning
we went back to the city to the town we
bought shovels
We buried it dead
buried dead and obviously we didn't know
what was going on so what why why was
that Convoy bombed if a deal it was bomb
it was bombed by the Americans but but
hadn't they made a deal for them yeah
they did make a deal I don't know why it
was I don't know why that happened all
we knew we we ran pretty much all night
from 8 pm to like early in the morning
where he was trying to hide
and it was it was did you manage to stay
together with your mates we stayed
together what happened was we eventually
got on Twitter on Twitter onto a like an
open back truck
and as I talk about driving
forward
um
we send the truck
and they said get in the truck so all my
friends as if Shafiq and and
another guy
um they managed to go on the truck he
didn't open back so they all ran jumped
on the truck and they've been pulled up
but I was asleep on the floor and as
I've got up
as I could put my one shoe on as I put
the second shoe on as I ran I stepped in
in some water it's a puddle and all my
shoes got wet so I took my shoes off and
I took my socks off and I ran barefooted
but I missed the truck I couldn't get on
because he drove off as he drove off my
friends they got jumped off before he's
not gone I'm gonna jump off as he drove
off and I only about 200 meters
as the truck drove forward it got bombed
and everybody on that truck died oh my
God every person died on that truck
so you were just seeing this happen in
front of you and obviously at that time
it's a bit of a surreal experience
experience
and it's like a good look at the movie
which so real and like obviously
you know the testosterones are high
Hearts pumping you've got a clue what
you're doing you don't know if to go to
Left call left go right go forward go
backwards all you see is flashes you can
see flashing all you can hear is a
helicopter and I'm shooting
and obviously them attacking them
shooting the convoys because a lot of
the the truck the trucks they had they
had ammunition in which they was going
to surrender to to the northern Lions so
obviously they've got rockets in there
they've got grenades in there they've
got bullets in there it's all on fire
it's all going everywhere it was like a
firework display pretty much
um and that was another days pretty much
a couple of hours walk
uh we got to a point where they made us
like a like a checkpoint so the northern
lines created this like this this is
like kind of front line where people
were going
no matter gate you know and they went
through there and they gave the keys for
the vehicles they gave domination they
gave the guns and then we were all tied
our hands were tied behind our backs and
obviously when we got to the front and
said you know what we're not part of
this you know we we we're not part and
what one of the guys said to me
um one of the fighters who spoke he said
you know what don't tell them people
from the UK
don't even say you here for whatever
reason just go with it
just shut your mouth and go with it and
hopefully you'll be taken to Canada with
us because if you open if you open you
say in Brits it's it's a way of them
making more money or keeping you back
foreign
so we thought okay just just be quiet
and when you say Northern Alliance just
for anyone who's not clear what was the
northern elections were the group who
were fighting against Taliban right
there was another lines who the
Americans and the Brits and and it
really the European
governments held it backed
um so General Dustin was I think they're
General
and I think the main leader his name was
I think
um so yeah that was another one so we
surrendered days the Taliban
and all the foreign Fighters had to
surrendered to another lions in return
of their safe passage to Canada where
Taliban still had their stronghold got
you but on the way they bombed them
anyway yeah I don't think it was the
northern Lions he was the Americans
right okay because I don't think there's
nothing Alliance has helicopters and
choppers right okay they don't have them
kind of artillery okay okay so okay so
you pass through and they say to you
don't say it because they'll just take
you out and separate you yeah so you
pass through and just didn't say
anything different yeah so we passed
through here then we walked for the
desert for I think nearly a day just
just walking and then obviously in the
night we they we was in a ditch it was a
massive ditch in between the mountain we
slept the night there we woke up the
next morning they bought our trucks
um just like straight you know like um
the long Vehicles they have so they load
us all on these trucks rammed us in
then they drove us for a Day to a place
called Mazar Sharif
um which was under the prison
we didn't know where it was going we
wasn't told obviously on the way we got
beats kicked punched by the guards you
know with the back of the gun of the
boats banging on our heads I think
everybody got some some you know
punctual kicks here
um eventually we we drive there for
nearly a day
um and yeah so then we stayed in that
prison for six weeks I believe
six weeks I think I think it's November
the first I got there
because I turned 18 on the third in that
prison
and I think we left that prison
December
thing just after Christmas
and what were conditions like in there
it gets worse right it gets worse I mean
it was bad anyway but every day got
worse and worse
so we get to the prison
um it was like a
each room I would say it was probably
five meters by five meters some rooms
were smaller
but each room it was it was rammed with
45 people so if you just imagine a five
meter by five meter room
a basic living room in the UK is around
like 40 people 45 people rammed grown
men grown adults there's no shop versus
facilities there's no food there's no
toilet facilities it's gone
use a toilet it was like an open hole
and there was
just
a mess everywhere you couldn't walk
there we had no sandals by the time we
got to the prison no shoes no socks bare
feet
uh
sleeping conditions horrendous we
couldn't sleep we had to sleep like
basically with our knees to her chest
sleep at that foot like I would sit
there if I was sweet it come to the
point that we had I didn't have enough
energy even to stand I lost that much
weight
we could you could it was a dip in my
collarbone
because I've been eaten for six seven
weeks and all we was getting is
basically scraps of bread like it was a
small piece of bread it was about
I would say about five inches
Circle and that would be cut into four
pieces like a pizza and we would have a
small pizza triangle and that's your
daily allowance
that's how you got that's all you got
all day all day and water was bare
minimum as well so we had to share a cup
of water
so it was it was tough but you know why
why were you in prison at this point
well we ain't all the time yeah but what
were you thinking like we was thinking
you're gonna just hold us here for a
couple of days yeah and they're gonna
move us further on
that's what we thought but obviously
they went back on the woods so whatever
the the deal was between the Taliban and
the northern lands
through the last thing keep to the word
for them it was Prisoners of War
and and they've seen the foreign
fighters to be
um a bounty really so they sold us on to
the Americans because the Americans were
looking for mainly foreign foreign
Fighters foreign in that sense as in
people from that country or foreigners
in like English English American okay um
Arab yeah yeah so anybody not from not
Afghani yeah and why did they want them
we was considered as high value right
okay so there would be more Intel from a
foreigner than an Afghanistan about how
to get there and what the different okay
right okay I see communication will be
easier yeah yeah to extract information
it's much easier
so um well we obviously never knew that
and did you have your stuff at this
point did you have your mouth
everything's gone by that time's gone
yeah barely had any clothes on me right
okay yeah yeah two of my shoes didn't my
socks I took my gloves my jacket how did
you end up from that position to moving
to Guantanamo so what happened after
that after Christmas
um we met the Red Cross
they came and spoke to them they tried
to help did you tell him who you were
yeah yeah we told them it's confidential
yeah so whatever we tell the Red Cross
it was it was it was confidential they
wouldn't go and tell the authorities who
were in charge so they they came back
and said you know we've we've told the
British government that you're here they
know that you you're here because
they've responded back to us so the
bridge the government of the UK knew he
was in that prison so if they wanted to
take us out they could have but they
didn't
why it's something that they
I believe it was drugstore who said let
them be taken by The Americans
hence why we went to court in the UK
took them off five in the British
government court and we were not won our
case hence why we got a payout without
nobody knowing
so they knew he was in prison they could
have brought us back home but they
didn't so I think it was Jack's straw he
said no let them be taken by the
Americans is that because they believed
you were terrorists
yeah the
the the the the the prison guards in
that country in in this head we need
translators we need people who can speak
English because we need to fill these
forms out for the Red Cross so like
idiots we said yeah we can translate
it was attack that they used to find out
who could speak English to give us to
find out who we are who speaks English
where they're from and then sell us on
to the Americans because from what we
was told it was they paid I think it was
35 000 for each prisoner they took
my God so 35 000 in Afghanistan at that
time
is stuck within the lottery it's like a
million pound
you can buy about you can buy you can
buy a villa
four times over probably and have loads
of money left over so for them it was
like we was like
gold mine so anyway they they took us
out we told them we speak English and
about two three days later they pulled
us out so we need to we need to come and
translate for us and then they basically
tie their hands behind about it back and
handed us over to Americans when I seen
the American first I thought the first
thing in my house
believe you know that that relief you
think
because I thought you know I can relate
to him I can talk to him and explain my
situation and they'll help us because
you the the image we have of Americans
back in them days in before 9 11. what
do you think of them do you think oh you
think you're he'll understand me you
know these guys are
you know the champions of Justice
they're gonna help me they'll they'll in
the movies we watch you know the movies
portrayed to be the good guys and you
think you know this is going to be
beneficial to me but lo and behold did I
know
it's going to be the complete opposite
it was worse than what the how the
Afghanistan treated us so did you
immediately start trying to say oh yeah
yeah trying to communicate and say this
is where we are this is why we're here
so obviously when we got to the makers
the the guy came to me to a room because
I'm I'm so and so part of the U.S
um forces blah blah I want to ask you a
few questions so obviously yeah you know
talks about talk to my talk to him told
me what I was when I was from to all the
notes they already had the information
they already had the information that we
was Brits somehow
um
I only said okay we're gonna help you
back over my head tied my tied the bag
with some duct tape and tied my eyes
because within the the back of your head
it's like a sandbag you can see into the
rice bag yeah you know they're like a
Hessian yeah you could see so they taped
the tape like I think it was masking
tape or duct tape around the eyes as
well so you can't see tighter hands with
um cable ties behind her back which was
like painful
and then tied our feet also with cable
ties
obviously when you walk in it's it's
it's romantic like nylon and it burns
your skin so by the time we walked from
like from here to there all my feet was
like bleeding because obviously I'm
pushing you from the back why can't you
just walk they were they they just tied
us up that's how they I think it was for
them it was like a
in the military they have a way to scare
people they attack you to tie you up to
make you feel like you're gonna die to
kill you executed was that it was that
Fear Factor they used and I think that's
what they're trying to do so we open up
tell the truth
and then to put us down in the line I
thought they're gonna shoot us that's
what I thought in my head
um
they they they put us on trucks
took us to an airport because we've got
they could hear planes landing and
taking off
um at that time they had like dogs
barking so when I looked down I could
see
just my chest area so I could see I was
on a runway on a Tarmac um and obviously
then they put us onto a
to a military plane tied us down the
pictures you see on on Google you know
with the goggles and stuff same kind of
thing
and then they flew us from
whatever he was to Kandahar
and they had the the um the airport as a
base
and and they put owners of they used to
us there really took us off got a
beating on the way
to Canada on the plane while hating you
yeah yeah I got a massive beating
because I spoke English
and I was trying to tell him look you
know what this is why I am shut up
obviously at that time
you I did my best to kind of just come
across you know you got the wrong person
I'm not I'm not a terrorist I'm not part
of Italian man I have no clue what's
going on
you know but for them there was for the
Americans it was like there was
brainwashed us to believe that every
person they met in Afghanistan was a
terrorist um
you know there was no such thing as
you're innocent of proven guilty you
just brown skinned or spoken he's got a
beard of which I grew a bit by then you
know I've been in Afghanistan since
I think it was November and they so like
it's been about nearly two months so
I've gone off here a fair amount here
so all they say is just the terrorists
they don't see a human being just to see
a see a killer and I think that's how
they treat us
um so when we go to Kandahar we had to
go through a process
so obviously you could hear all the
other detainees all the places
with me
um at the time I could I could hear them
um and obviously I needed to be like
they gave us water to drink when we was
on the trucks before we got on the plane
so you drunk a lot of water I needed I
haven't drank water for six weeks so now
he's gone through me I need a wee really
bad because I need to go to toilet I
need to go toilet so all they did was my
hands were tied my back head covered
and and they said well you'll go toilet
what do you do here and just took my
pants down instead of me
and I couldn't be
I couldn't I couldn't wait because I
knew there was a lot of gods and I knew
there was female female guards there as
well so I'm kneeling down hands talking
about might be on my back is pulling my
pants down
and he wanted me and now
the thought of like them watching me
it was not so the not so much the men
the women them watching me and like I
gotta pee and now I can't pee hmm and
it's like I feel like I'm my insides
explode So eventually you know a focus
and I try to blanket for now and now we
pulled my pants up then if we go through
like a process where
they they took our fingerprints
photographs of her faces
um they gave me a band with a number and
they put us in a in a it was like a barn
it was a makeshift
kind of look like a metal hanger and
they made like prisoners out of it with
barbed wire sexually off like I think it
was like four sections on one side and
the walkway in the middle
so they threw us in in in there it was
about eight to ten people per
cage and then they came through Food
House you know the MREs
American
Army feel food and obviously I haven't
ate in such a long time I didn't see if
it was Halal or not I just opened the
pack and run them down so there I can
remember there was like um frankfurters
sausages there were some pork ones there
was chicken and a lot of other detainees
who I met there there was Arabs and they
wouldn't eat it because he was chicken
and beef and
and I knew in this situation he got no
choice you got to eat everyone's packets
and I was obviously stuffed then I feel
sick and I was sick all over the place
um the next morning they took me to
another another place
and then we just was just there for I
think another month I think just an open
it was an open open field
um like a tent
and we had to sit in the daytime we had
to sit out of the tent blazing sun legs
out hands other
couldn't move couldn't talk
in the night we had to sleep we had to
do what they said it was very controlled
um we couldn't talk
again if we had to go to the toilet
there was a bucket
just a normal metal bucket so you go and
do number two there number one in front
of everybody there was no privacy you
couldn't the game was like blankets in
the night like heavy type of blankets
but it's like taking a blanket and
wrapping yourself and doing a Wii or a
poo it doesn't work you can't do it then
there's no water to wash yourself
there's no toilet paper to wipe your
Bump nothing the only payment we got is
when we should get the meals they should
give like a packet and they should be
like a main meal
a dessert
and the sugar would be taken out
anything that sugary they would take
that out like a cake pound cake that
would take that out and they'll leave a
small packet of tissue you know like
that we have like clinics okay it was
much smaller enough just to wipe your
hand I said you wipe your bags over
there you can't do it it's impossible
so like for nearly
the time I spent in
the prison before six weeks a month
there I couldn't wash my backside
and you're doing a I'm doing a poo in a
bucket where everyone's done it and it's
and it's full so you're squatting I'm
doing your best not to touch the rim and
then you improve and you're trying to
balance and try to cover yourself at the
same time and the and the worst thing
was the guards would always come and
watch you when you're taking a poo
yeah to make us feel like we're animals
yeah to degrade us and that's what he
was it that's the tactics
and and
you know it was it was difficult like
you need to go to the toilet and or take
away
and you couldn't because I'm standing
right next to you
the only thing that was between me and
the God was a bad boy
you can put your hands to the bar where
so it's like me and you I did the barbed
wire and they put the bucket there and
he's fighting them
and then and I mean it was it was
awkward and it was a horrible experience
you know and it was extremely the
weather in Afghanistan is bizarre in
Kandahar in the daytime is extremely hot
to the point where it's scorching hot
like him sitting out
it's not just the desert you can see in
there he scores you know
can't go under his attempt to get shade
because you're not allowed to why not it
was the polished their their policy
right you got to be in in their site in
their View
um and they would force you to drink six
liters of water every day okay which was
good you know water's not bad but like
they would literally Force you like they
would give us a bottle
and the whole leadership there was all
in the line and it'll make you drink it
you've got to drink the whole lot in one
go you won't go six liters the one liter
per time right okay
this is Elite you're gonna drink it so
they want you to stay hydrated
because of this doesn't heat but then
you need to go toilet then you're gonna
wee then you're gonna read in front of
them so it was all games they was
playing with us to make us feel degraded
and humiliated to break us down
basically to the point there for the
point where we we say what they want um
um
and in the night it was freezing cold it
would be like minus one two it's the
blank as they gave us it wasn't enough
so they gave us like um gloves to wear
and in the night what we do we take the
gloves off and put enough Heat
so you always had to walk if you like go
to the toilet you'd walk looking down on
the floor and then walk the toilet when
you sit in the toilet you can look down
you never can look up you can't talk to
the guard while looking up and looking
into his eyes so what would have
happened if you had just continued to
stretch out or move you get punished
like physically or physically yeah
physically so some of the guys who were
not as complex compliant with the rules
and laws of the camp they will be taken
out handcuffed and they would cuff their
feet and the hands together backwards
like a scorpion yeah yeah so they'll
leave them
on the floor in the open air day and
night for days
that was a punishment
so if it was hot cold no blanket that's
what happened so if you know what I'd
rather just not look at them and just do
what they say other guy get rather get
permission I'm getting punched anyway
that's worse
so yeah and where so where just to
remind me where exactly were you at this
point in time still in Canada still in
Canada it was no army base so they
turned into a like a military base right
and at what point was it that you then
got transferred it was February the 14th
I think okay Valentine's Day and today
oh God yeah that's my gift to me yes did
they tell you that you were going I
suppose at that point in time you didn't
know what Guantanamo Bay was no I never
knew what that I never knew what Cuba
was yeah so did they come to you one day
and say you're going to this new place
or did they no what they said what
happened was obviously over the period
of I think six weeks while I was in in
Afghan in Canada
some of the gods were good I can't say
they're all well bad
you can't say that there was a few
guards who were actually
not happy with what the what was going
on what they was doing to us
and and they they spoke to us you know
on the sly you know you're okay you know
I'm sorry
you know it's out of my hands I can't do
anything and one of the guys said to me
while I was getting tailgated once
because we obviously went to like like
to get interrogated in that period by
the Americans buy their MiFi by their
Mark six
um by the home office the British almost
came in and spoke to us oh they did yeah
yeah three four times before I went to
guantano and they
said so they knew you were British yeah
you heard your story but they didn't did
anything because Jack saws I know take
him let them take them okay so
they some of the guards were like
quite quite genuine and they said to it
they said to me
if you wear an orange suit
on the day or when you get moved out
from here that means you're gonna fly
out somewhere if you went to orange suit
you're gonna go up to a place called
Guantanamo
where's Cuba
he goes South America
um
so even even then at that time Santa
make I was like well where's South
America like Brazil and stuff like I
definitely really know about these kind
of places because it's not something
that I was I never traveled other than
Bangladesh and Pakistan and these kind
of countries
um
he said to me if you wear blue you're
going to go back to your country
whatever your country is
something on the day when I got
processed they shaved my hair they
shaved my beard because I had a lot of
head lice and the body lice all over me
like my underarms my groin
it was everywhere in my clothes it was
it was bad I got until this day I got
marks of of them biting me wow it was
that bad because we didn't shower for
like
pretty much since they're going against
that other shower ones in when I first
got up the first morning
after that I pretty much
I think three times that's it there was
no other time obviously time it was in
in prison in Chicago which was I think a
month then six weeks in kandaha there
was no shows so obviously medium
traveling he's Dusty's dirty sweaty it's
in the same place of people in together
yeah there's no toilet paper so you can
just imagine how he smelt it was it was
a nice it wasn't pleasant at all
um
my hair was knotted I couldn't put my I
had long hair then like much longer
finger through my hair
um you look at afro um like forming
locks yeah yeah yeah
um and I had lice everywhere like it was
it was that bad like I would constantly
itch oh it's the point where my nails
wouldn't grow
wow and I know itch my body and they
would bleed so what they did was they
took us out they they processed us we
are getting took fingerprints
photographs shave their head shave the
page shave it all out on the arms our
private parts they put like many some
kind of medicine on us so their life
dies
gave us new set of clothes it was orange
jumpsuits handcuffed was put a belt
around our waist goggles earmuffs uh
muff mittens and they basically put us
on the plane so then I knew I'm gonna go
to Guantanamo but I never knew where
that was
and was that you was it all of you your
group or was it just you no there was it
so me it was in you and your three mates
no so we once we got to the once the
Americans took hold of us we were
segregated it was split up because they
knew we was friends so Asif and shavik
went to guantano before me I think they
went a month before me they went pretty
much pretty much straight away
um to Guantanamo I went a month probably
a couple of weeks later
so um
obviously regardless of on the plane the
plane generals
just bizarre
um it was a military plane so obviously
they they tied us they changed us to the
wall of the plane so we couldn't go
forward go backwards it was like kind of
stock so our hands were tied
uh with the cuffs and obviously that has
a a ring where from that ring there'll
be another chain goes to your backwards
padlock from that chain there was
another change of the floor to your feet
shackles so three it's called a three
piece suit they call it so what you see
in the American films
um so it's that then they chained us to
the wall of the of the plane and
obviously
we got taken to to Guantanamo one it's
another remember was
um
they gave us sandwiches they gave us
peanut butter sandwiches you know but
bear in mind we got
we've got mittens on
so she put
the sandwich in my hand in between
my my hand
I got mittens on so I can't I can't grab
it properly
neither can I come forward to eat it
so I'm I'm seeing all this chained up to
the max where there's no movement I
can't go forward can't go outside
I can't even lift my legs or my knees up
to push my arm up to my to my mouth
and and at least half an hour event I'm
struggling I'm hungry when I eat this
peanut butter sandwich because I can
smell it if I want to eat this but can't
I can't eat it she came half an hour
later because she opens my earmuffs
so you don't want to eat them of the
sandwich I said to her well how am I
supposed to eat it you've tied in your
dog
she put the moth back to the sandwich
and point in the bed yeah
the funny thing is she coming back five
minutes later and put somebody an apple
there
she puts an apple in my hand
I'm thinking like what I just told you
you've tied me up so what's the point
now
ten minutes later I took the Apple threw
down a bit because they I could see
through them for the um the goggles you
know here yeah the bottom yeah you could
see the the the the Recycled bags bin
bags and they're throwing all the food
in there then she came and gave me a
bottle of water
and I think it's just mind games
and again because there was no she could
see there was no they knew that yeah it
just this is mind games and when I got
off
and they had to I had to go through the
process again where they do your name
you know you address
um they asked me the Red Cross was there
to write a letter that's the first one I
wrote a letter to my parents
um
and they strip you naked basically to
put you in the shower give your soap
some shampoo show yourself and the
Medics go to me
put your leg
I said well your your colleague who has
quoted me kicked me about 20 times
and I couldn't feel my legs I was
dragging my leg behind me it cost me
I'll be fine
we're fine and it was blue like for
about three weeks it was purple
so he'd known that you couldn't not move
he was just looking at your excuse too I
think I think all the only one who got
beat he was everybody it was it was it
was a psychological game they was
playing with us where they say to us
don't move
but you're moving because you're moving
to kick you well we wasn't moving we was
moving because the blue the ball was
moving naturally you wanna you you won
the uh you know when you Mum water
aren't you
so obviously then we go through the
process then obviously I got to my cage
he was like a dog kennel and that that
so
Guantanamo Bay had been opened as a
reaction to 9 11. so you guys must have
been some of the first prisoners there
yeah we were we were the first prisoners
there some of the I mean I wasn't the
first one the first batch
the first group of people I was probably
the third or the fourth right so um
there was only a handful of prisoners
when I got there right so it wasn't full
at that point no no no no it was like
50 60 is that
um so obviously we got there we've gone
through the process uh they told me the
rule Camp rules editor Camp rules set up
on a board read that
took me to my
dog kennel which he was a doctor that
wasn't I mean if you if you if you if
you Google the image of Camp x-ray he
said okay no it's where you would keep
in an animal and it was it was a
concrete floor that gave us a very silly
um thin mat to sleep on
two buckets one had one one had water
into shower with in in your cell in your
space one was to to poo in and read and
the guy was her
um a bottle of water to drink
a
a toothbrush that was cut
so you know so we can't use this weapon
so that's that's what I think that's a
normal
um prison procedure they do and a bottle
of soap shampoo toothpaste
and two towels
and then obviously we had to sit in the
middle of the cell we couldn't lead on
the cell on the fence I couldn't lead on
the fence we had to sit in the middle of
the fence all the way couldn't move
couldn't walk
couldn't do anything just sit there then
at night time they would say it was time
to sleep lie down so we had to sleep
when they tell us we just sit up when
they close even the days are embed or
was did you have to like no it was a
concrete floor yeah they gave like a
foam mat yeah she's got about probably
10 mil thick authorities a green mat you
know
um and all big smuts yeah exercise much
like that when we're talking about being
in Guantanamo Bay a lot of the stories
that have come out from there and
there's been whole documentaries made
out about the the horrific torture that
went on in there did you see any of that
were you witness to any of them we
didn't see it physically with our eyes
um but we are I experienced it myself
and obviously when you're in
um in Camp
um when you're in your interrogation
room or the booth you can hear the
person next to you getting tortured and
you're walking down the aisle you can
hear screams from each room but
physically scene is always closed off
and you say you experienced it yourself
so what did you so like for example the
only thing that they didn't do with me
was to
the other every
every online that we've gone through
like Shore cycling of of show tracking
is basically it's it's it's it's a hook
in the on the floor
um it's a metal hook
as what they do they get separated
handcuffs they cuff your hand to the
hook the floor so you're hooked up and
your feet also are cuffed to that so
you're squatting
yeah they leave you in that position for
like hours somebody days
you can't go to the toilet
so you you defecate
urinate on yourself
even though you're screaming they got
loud music playing he's normally it was
the rock music you're like heavy metal
music which we're not used I'm not used
to and it's not really Pleasant video
that kind of music person but it's on
for like 24 hours 48 hours so somebody
will be there for like a day two days
it's in the air smoke on fire room
strobe lights on
um lights up and they make it really
cold so they put the aircon really cold
are you there are in that position
another leg starts cramping your cast
cramp
hamstrings and camping your bum's
cramping comes in your belly Comes Here
Comes you can't you can't get out
which I mean and obviously the car
sometimes they would bring dogs dogs in
barking at your face
they would come in Kick you punch you
whack you so obviously if you if you're
in that position pretty much tiptoeing I
mean because you you're on the pull
forward you're not fronting your foot
because if you've gone flat on your foot
it pulls onto your wrist the coughs dig
into your wrist so you're kind of like
balancing on your tip on your toes a
ball of your foot
so when they would come in with the dogs
of you you pull him back onto you
because the dog's in your face oh they
would punch you and kick you so you
would fall that way and obviously you're
falling away where you you fall down but
you're restricted
to drag you up put you back kick you the
other way then you've got that and all
the time it's lovely the costs are
digging into your wrists into your
ankles so you you know it's all that
kind of stuff and would you were they
asking you to do something like were
they saying confess basically they were
saying that over and over again like you
need to confess you need to confessions
and if you do this sub line to us right
you know we know you're there right
we've got evidence we've got the
detainees who've said you was there that
was there with you they've came clean
you need to come clean I mean you can
start over blah blah so and did you did
you hear did any of the inmates ever
tell you any stories about you know
waterboarding or the Torches or things
like that yeah yeah but you know people
disgusted but it wasn't it wasn't openly
you would know because you when they
would come back they wouldn't be in the
right mind frame and two three days
later
then start talking same with me really
what happened to me or come back you'd
be quiet but I think me and as even
Shafiq were because we were so young and
we got put together
it became a part where like I would go
and then oh okay he's got beat Michael
bruises they would say like
how you feeling man
I think we make made into a joke Like A
coping mechanism that we would take the
take the mick out of someone getting
battered
or if you couldn't because I like the
pain and you shook me today
so it was I mean I mean he was so young
so we could make a joke out of it
because there was no other there's no
other way out of it really like in your
mind to get it out of your mind
you know how'd you how do you deal with
that in your mind so how do you how do
you what how do you keep your mind sane
during that
what were you thinking of on a daily
basis
it's hard it's it's really tough to
explain
but you know humans we adapt into
situations
and I think like anybody who's gone
through
tough time in life they they the body
and the mind just adapts into the human
nature
it's just part of us we we just evolve
into
something that we know and we have
something in us that comes out to
survive and I think that's what it was
just just survival but saying that now
it's it's different for me
saying that it's easy for me to say that
because I was 18.
not wives no children no
responsibilities no burden single guy
nothing to care about in the world
eventually you did confess didn't you
yes and so what was it you confessed to
and how did that come about so so
basically being there for nearly I think
nearly a one and a half years we lost
the hope of coming home um
and It ultimately it came down to we
realized that all they wanted Americans
was they wanted
they wanted
a scapegoat so we were with Lambs to the
slaughter basically so they they needed
the proof of Dominican people that by
opening guantanaman and by inviting it
by invading Afghanistan they've
Justified the means so they needed
people to be guilty because they
couldn't find nobody who was guilty and
that was a problem they couldn't take
anybody to court and actually prosecute
them for 9 11. for those who did they
died in the blue plane
um and obviously The Mastermind behind
it was Osama bin Laden he was nobody
found so they needed to justify the
actions so we realized what they wanted
was a false
um
they want you to testify to what they
said so what they were saying to us was
there was a video a rally that took
place I believe in
2011.
where Muhammad Atta the main hijacker of
911 was in a rally in Afghanistan where
Osama Bin Laden was given a sermon
in that sermon there was a video on the
sermon
and there was a few guys it was it was a
massive Gathering and one of the
questions they asked me when I was in
Guantanamo what was you wearing when you
traveled to Afghanistan I said I had
like joggers tracksuits
what brand were they Adidas so what does
Adidas have they have three stripes so
in the video
they had a guy who looked nothing like
me who had a fleece top on with it and
he was an Adidas it was fake you could
serve on mine was fake but they could
see the stripes so they said look you
told us he was wearing a black Adidas
fleece top that's you there in that
rally with muhammadata in 2000 I think
it was either see what he was the
problem was that Americans they couldn't
work out the dates if it was 2011
or to um
it was something like you know the date
we we had the date the month and the
year yeah so they wasn't sure if it was
like the first of for example first of
August 2011 yeah or the 11th of the
first year which way around the months
and then so they they didn't know so
either way it doesn't matter because I
was actually on
um I was doing community service I got
in trouble with the police in the UK and
I was doing community service so under
two days I was doing community service I
was cleaning that I was painting a
church
[Music]
on both dates on both days right so he
didn't matter because I had I had 150
hours of community service
so it doesn't matter what I was where
what days they threw at me I was in the
UK and the police knew that and the
probation officer knew that so the
information was on the system in the UK
they knew that but they needed to pin
someone down so at the end after months
and months and nearly years I've gone by
we actually to discuss the amongst us
because we all put together we say you
know what we've said the truth it's not
working mr5 turned around to the maker
and said maybe there was traveling on
false passports
that's what America was that's what the
bridge said to the Americans
it's not them but maybe they've traveled
on false passports
maybe they've done something wrong like
just trying to find some kind of yeah so
anyway we what we said is that we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna confess to
whatever you want us to do
and that was because of what we went
through so they told you so they put us
in stress which in the beatings the loud
music the hot and cold so at the end I
thought you know what let's just say we
were there because I actually lost hope
of coming home so I thought it doesn't
matter if I say I am a terrorist I am
Bin Laden's
right hand man he makes no difference
because I'm going to be here it's
irrelevant now and then I got home so
I'm gonna stay here so it doesn't really
matter who what they believe I'm not
going home so let me see by saying I am
a terrorist or Bin Laden is right now I
Knew by 9 11 I was on the next
Mastermind so I said to the American the
intelligent officer I said you know what
you write out you print out what you
want to say I'll just sign it on the dot
so they went and signed this confession
I signed a date
and that's all it was and believe you or
not all the torture stopped
wow all the harsh treatment stopped
because he's giving them what they
wanted yeah but do you think they knew
you were innocent they knew like a
hundred percent they knew they had no
suspicion they just wanted someone to
admit yeah commit to saying that yeah
and that was all about but they knew if
they take us to court
they wouldn't win yeah because it's just
nonsense every most cool cases they've
gone to the courts in America of all
these prisoners it's been thrown out
every person from Guantanamo till this
day
majority I would say 80 98 has been
released if I got a handful of people
even till this day there's people who've
been
who've been said them innocent and they
should be freed they've been there for
like 19 years they're not still freeing
them but they've been proven to be
innocent and the government American
government said yeah these guys are
aren't terrorists I'm not the minister
but they don't release them because I'm
scared of the backlash because they've
been I mean a lot of guys I know who are
in prison who are met they've come out
of prison
and they want revenge Vengeance they've
gone back to Syria to fight against
Americans they weren't terrorists to
begin with but they've made them into
terrorists and that's what I'm scared of
and and rightfully so if if you've
talked to some guy to the next end where
he's lost his family lost his home he's
in a one revention thinking I didn't do
nothing but you've kept me for x amount
of years my family's destroyed causes
you you destroy my entire life
I'm gonna get I want payback so they've
gone and joined groups
and have fought against American
soldiers in Syria in places like that in
Iraq
so do you really blame them was it hard
for you not to go down that Avenue
mentally no because I mean I was young I
didn't lose nobody yeah I came back and
I thought
22. I can rebuild my life I got married
to my wife who was here Within
28 days have I got released
so actually let me just bridge that Gap
so you confessed and then how much
longer were you in Guantanamo for
probably another year another year wow
but just held now as a terrorist yeah so
now you've confessed so they're going
yeah he's he's a terrorist he's
confessed to what we've said he is how
on Earth do you then become how do you
get released from that point I don't
know this is the funny part where we
actually don't know so what happened was
they took us out one day took all the
Bliss out all the all the English all
the English lands took us to a different
cell different block
and then all we've seen is the Breeze
Police
for what the Bobby's doing here
those in their uniform please
we thought this is odd they're not not
in my head I'm thinking it's Americans
just to block things pretending that
we're gonna go home so anyway anyway we
see the police they tell us who they are
I've been from London blah blah blah
we're gonna take you home tomorrow we
think yeah whatever before it's just
yeah another mind game next morning they
gave us they gave us new trainers jeans
a top t-shirt jacket post on a plane and
Hannah's office to the bricks please
bring on the plane
everyone on the RAF you know the UK
plane I thought
odd and he's just such a thriller moment
from being locked up in a prison
what I'll tell you when I knew I knew I
was gonna go home not up until the point
where the demand goes off because we're
going to the plate
and the American guards were holding one
they usually hold you one here one on
this side and they hold you tight hold
your shoulder hold your arm when you're
cuffed as soon as you go to the top of
the plane as we're going to get into the
plane
um the police officer goes uncover them
take the chains off
and the American God looks at each other
he looks at the police officer are you
sure
the police officer looks like both of
them because yeah yeah we're sure
take the chains off so they took our
chains off and what they did as soon as
they took the chains off and the padlock
off they pushed
us towards the police officer as if
we're gonna turn around and kill both I
mean and there was like hundreds of
armed Gods behind us but that's how
scared they were scared they were of us
it was Unreal so you get flown back
straight to the UK yeah and then is
there a debriefing period so we we get
we get we come over to the UK we land
as soon as we hit the airspace that
really highlights on the bridge him on
the rest for this and that
um you know they give that Rice they
read the rise onto you
um and then obviously they
they detain or they don't arrest or they
detain us take us to patterning pending
Square PlayStation key booster for 24
hours interviews once
asked me about
um more treatment in Guantanamo ask me
if I'm a terrorist asked me if I'm part
of any groups in the UK if you know this
group that person this person they have
a huge losing list of group and all I
said no comment
no comment 24 hours later that you're
free to go
and they just open the door
I said you're free to go and now for me
that was a bit of a weird moment because
for two and a half years you've been
locked up like animal
like we couldn't even go to the toilet
of the shower without being chained
no less than someone says to me you're
free to go he's opened the door I said
you're free to go
and I stood there for half an hour
it's literally five now and they said to
me do you want anybody to come get you
and I said
I don't know
that I made a phone call and the first
was I made a phone call was to to my
wife
and then I followed my dad
and there he was on the way to London he
was there was in traffic
and then my solicitor at the time said
to me
come with me
and then what the police decided to do
they they there was a there was a lot of
press outside the police station so they
took me around the like around the back
into a police vehicle and they found my
dad said where are you and they took me
secretly to my to meet my dad in a hotel
so it was a bit of a weird moment like
from being locked up like an animal for
two and a half years literally
and I I didn't take a full step
for two and a half years because we was
always in Chains so them shackles are
quite limited a couple of feet not even
that okay so you you're shuffling like a
penguin and I always said you're free to
walk and it was like
it just felt so weird to walk and I can
remember getting to the hotel I got
there before my dad
and the lady asked me have you got rid
of the reservation and it just chilled
weird you know talking to someone and
she handed me the keys she took me to my
room
and I got in my room and I was like free
to do what I wanted president
and it was like a weird moment and I can
remember
I'm holding my dad obviously we cried
and you know he was angry at the same
time you know
why did you go on this and that um yeah
they moved to mackie's to have some food
the first thing I did went to McDonald's
I couldn't have a cheeseburger because
I'll eat them I had a filet fish
strawberry shake
yeah and I can remember like clearly
standing in in the shop in the road
touching the Lamppost like feeling the
Lamppost which was weird but that's not
what the hell are you doing
I said you you understand I haven't had
no physical contact with anything with
any human for two and a half years what
when you came out because am I writing
thinking you successfully took the UK to
court maybe the US what happened what
happened was we had a we had a lawsuit
against the US and the and the UK
government it was a UK government was
this you and your friends it was all the
Brits in this country oh right okay I
think there's like
13 16 of us
um
and and we we went to court but it was
an outer quarter settlement
so he didn't go to court today he wants
to go to court because they would have
to open up all their secret evidence and
it would have to be made public right it
was it was done it was done
um when the new government came in power
when the conservatives came in we had to
call me there by five
few meetings with our lawyers and he was
an outer courts helmet and was it I I
mean I don't want to pry too deeply but
was it an amount that you think everyone
would have been happy with
I don't think for the two and a half
years I went through he was not enough
yeah no Mania
no don't get me wrong it was a it was a
massive substantial amount of money
which has changed my life and Mark his
life for sure
like I can
retire
I don't need to work I work I still work
um I could have retired when they paid
me but I didn't retire I went to graft I
went to work and the only reason I went
to work
is because of our young kids and my kids
need to see that nothing in life comes
from free unless you craft because if
they just said oh that would give us
this inheritance that would become bombs
there will be they wouldn't be
hard-working individuals so they need to
be hard work individual and they need to
know that nothing will come on the lap
for nothing
so hence why I still work and I work
believe it or not work
every day even the weekends now and I
don't need to work what do you do I'm a
meeting engineer right
so you know it's just and I work stupid
hours you know some days I can come home
at midnight some days I'll come out two
in the morning
at least the way I am because you want
to be an example to the children yep
and so America the US who actually
imprisoned you was there anything there
he had a court case there
um obviously I don't think
for the first five years I kept up with
it it's the progress
I'm just let it go now I'm right so I
don't know what's going on
other life is still happening or if
they've just dropped you I don't know is
that just because it's something you
want to move on past just not bother
with it yeah to be honest with you like
even if it I get the conversation I got
I would be okay
because I've always been that kind of
person not offended for myself I don't
look out for handouts I'm not a person
who's gonna sit here I think well I got
paid out I don't need to work and do you
keep up with Guantanamo Bay like what's
happening there
two or seven points to remind me of the
last
four years I've kind of
I haven't because life's changed for me
in the last four years
um
sorry I just want to rebuild some things
in my life and move on
and it's a chapter that I want to close
really
um
you know as I said before it didn't
really affect me because I was young but
I don't know maybe when I'm old when
have not when I'm when I retire and have
nothing to do my kids get married and
they move on and life kind of slows down
because at the moment I live out of life
Vaseline my life is very busy like from
day to day weekends it's like I don't
have time for nothing I'm always busy at
work or this or that my kids this wife
needs that this wife is that so it's
always busy so I think when I'm older
and I'm like 60 70 probably 80 if I live
that long I hope I don't
um thought I'd be able to reliant on
anybody really you know when you're mold
trying to be a billion or nobody so I'd
rather live a life where I'm fit and
healthy I'll just die
you know I thought I really
be all and live and be a burden of my
children
um
I think if I live to that age
I think maybe you'll affect me could
they usually say these kind of things
affect people as they get older
and I don't want to be affected when I'm
old and my children need to deal with it
because I've not allowed them to deal
with it now because I've kind of kept
I've kind of shielded them from my life
of what I've gone through I've never
gone home and screamed or this has
happened to me and why it happened to me
I mean I've not done that and I won't do
it but I don't know if I will do it
and I wish I don't so why one of the
reasons why I wish I died early so I
don't see why I don't want to see my
children see me and that affecting them
in their life because he has an alcohol
effect on their life on their wife and
the kids
so I'd rather I'd rather be the end of
that
problem and buy with it
and the final question I wanted to ask
you is are you still mates with yeah
we're still friends but I think are like
um
over the years French's friendship
evolves doesn't it
um we were single
when we went to prison we were single
when we came out
um passive went back to Pakistan I went
back with him no wow yeah he married the
girl he he wasn't going to marry okay so
that really took place eventually six
years only six years down the line she
waited for six years so that's good
um
and obviously we've all got married
um we've got kids I've got six kids
everyone's busy with their life so his
kids his daughter's like doing well in
school
his son's doing well my kids are doing
well everyone's busy with the kids so we
don't really see each other now so
obviously as he's kind of retired it
doesn't really work
um he's lost my health issues back
problems and stuff well look real it's
been amazing to meet you it's been great
to have you in and it's been like uh
it's really an incredible and disturbing
story and I genuinely think it's
something that more people should know
about thanks so much mate yeah
specifically I was more annoyed or
pissed off okay because I knew like they
wouldn't send me the gel because I was a
miner and at the time in the UK no Miner
has been sent to jail
under the computer misuse Act
that's changed
recently there was one case where it has
been the case but at the time it hasn't